quiero que piensen cuál es su último
recuerdo algo que los haya marcado en el
último año o en los últimos meses algo
que haya sido importante para ustedes
eso es algo fácil porque es algo que
acaba de suceder
pero si yo les pido que recuerden algo
de su infancia de los primeros años de
su vida quizá nos resulte un poco más
difícil
es lo que pasa en nuestra mente porque
perdemos ciertos recuerdos
conforme vamos creciendo nuestro cerebro
va formando conexiones neuronales esto
va creando conocimiento recuerdos a lo
largo de nuestra vida vamos aprendiendo
y creciendo constantemente pero después
de cierto tiempo todas esas conexiones
que no fueron lo suficientemente fuertes
se vuelven otras conexiones nuevas para
generar recuerdos y memorias
por eso nos es muy difícil recordar lo
que pasó antes seguramente no recordamos
cuando ese panda nos tomó la foto
el 30 por ciento de nuestro aprendizaje
es visual y el 55% es visual y auditivo
eso quiere decir que más o menos el 85 o
90 por ciento de nuestro aprendizaje es
en parte visual somos seres visuales y a
lo largo de la historia nos hemos dado
cuenta de eso en la prehistoria en las
cavernas plasma vamos la realidad que
vivíamos los recuerdos que queríamos
para nuestras futuras generaciones
rituales comida etcétera
hemos cambiado entonces los ojos por
lentes nuestro nervio óptico por
sensores nuestras pupilas por diafragmas
y todo esto gracias a la tecnología
recordamos días y a veces también
momentos lo decía para veces y hablando
de recuerdos algunos de los presentes
aún tiene esas viejas cámaras de rollo
algunos de los aquí presentes la utiliza
todavía
hoy en día es muy difícil debido al
avance de la tecnología contar todavía
con cámaras de rollo y es muy difícil
encontrar los procesos para generar
fotografía
pero hagamos un poquito de conciencia
esta es una cámara de rollo
y antes para generar un recuerdo era
algo completamente tardado y complicado
era lo que tenemos que hacer comprar un
rollo abrir la tapa ponerlo ajustarlo
cuidar la apertura la velocidad la
sensibilidad y entonces salíamos a la
calle oa nuestras vacaciones con
solamente 24 o 36 fotos para recordar
eso eso que para futuras generaciones
iban a ser nuestros recuerdos para
nuestros hijos para nuestros nietos
nos volvimos un poco inconscientes de
qué es lo que está detrás de esto
alguien sabe por qué el sonido del
obturador es este
saben que hay un espejo detrás de él
seguramente no y muchos de nuestros
aparatos digitales emiten este sonido
y ni siquiera sabemos a qué se debe
podían pasar semanas y meses hasta que
revelamos nuestras fotografías y
podríamos saber recordar este ajustado
ese peso que habíamos perdido en las
vacaciones
qué es lo que está pasando ahora en que
nos hemos convertido qué es lo que
estamos tomando fotografían y
documentando de nosotros pues si a
nosotros mismos en diferentes versiones
nosotros mismos comiendo nosotros mismos
de vacaciones nosotros mismos viéndonos
a nosotros mismos en un espejo
es lo que ha pasado últimamente durante
los últimos años y gracias al avance
tecnológico nuestros dispositivos
inteligentes nuestros celulares sobre
todo tienen cámaras potentes con una
buena resolución y eso nos ha provocado
olvidarnos un poco de estos aparatos de
toda esta mecánica que hay detrás
y qué es lo que ha pasado se ha
incrementado muchísimo cada vez son más
las personas que tienen acceso a la
telefonía y por lo por lo mismo tiene
acceso a una cámara
nuestras tabletas estas cámaras incluso
las cámaras digitales han ido en
incremento y qué es lo que hacemos con
esos aparatos super tecnológicos
costosos y todos tomamos fotos de
nuestras mascotas de lo que comemos y de
los lugares que visitamos
como somos seres visuales ese rojo les
llama la atención verdad
esos son el total de fotografías que se
va a tomar al final de este año es un
pronóstico de todas esas fotografías
cuántas realmente vale la pena recordar
fue entonces cuando decidí detenerme
dije yo no puedo ser parte de esto no
puedo estarme tomando fotos a mí mismo
en cada lugar en cada evento al que voy
oa la comida o las mascotas o de
cualquier cosa porque ya se estaba
convirtiendo en un vicio
y dije qué puedo hacer para cambiar eso
para poner ese granito de arena por lo
menos de mi parte y la respuesta estaba
ahí en la calle aunque ustedes no lo
creen
porque la calle porque la calle te
entrega personajes ambientes
arquitectura nostalgia hay de todo en la
calle y es libre y es gratis y
cualquiera lo puede utilizar
qué es lo que necesito para ir a la
calle café porque es sustancial para
tomar buenas fotografías
la cámara ya sea de rollo o ya sea
digital la calle que como les digo
siempre está ahí y un buen libro porque
para estar en la calle uno tiene que
esperar y esperar mucho y que mejor que
esperar leyendo
he encontrado en la calle me he
encontrado personajes muchos personajes
gente que disfruta de cosas sencillas
que sí son alimentos pero retratados de
una manera distinta
me he topado con amigos y me ha llegado
esa nostalgia de extrañar a los propios
sobre todo con esta foto cuando la tomé
pensé inmediatamente en mi mejor amigo
que está fuera del país fue una foto que
me marcó
o esta foto de las comadres vestidas
igual platicando conversando después de
tantos años con el valor de la amistad
sólido como debe de ser
me he topado con imágenes un poco
incluso hasta surrealista se podría
decir
esta foto es en aguascalientes en la
feria de aguascalientes y era una niña
que se estaba quejando con la mamá
iglesia mamá es que me duele el diente
porque está comiendo un elote y la mamá
le dice a ver espérame y agárralo y
empezó a sacar a hurgar y el diente y
justo en ese momento es capturar eso
cuando voy a volver a tomar otra
fotografía así alves nunca
no todo en la calle sino todo en el
público es agradable
también te hace ser empático te hace
entender al otro y te hace sentir por
medio de otras personas como este hombre
al que vemos triste derrotado con algún
dolor con algún acontecimiento que
seguramente no fue grato
seguramente es un momento que él no
quisiera recordar pero también los malos
momentos son los que nos fortalecen
y qué puedo decir
de esta fotografía
esta fotografía fue tomada aquí en esta
ciudad en el zoológico
cuando tomé esta foto no lo creía dije
de verdad es expresiones de expresión es
humana eso no es un animal
muchas veces somos inconscientes de eso
cuando yo tomé esta foto estaba
caminando por la jaula de los simios y
varias personas estaban aventando
alimentos donde ellos estaban
había una frustración enorme porque no
alcanzaban el alimento y tenían que
atravesar la reja para agarrarlo
tomé varias y una de ellas fue esta
fotografía
cuando llegue a la casa la descarga en
el ordenador y las vi
me dejaron pensando por mucho tiempo esa
foto la imprime la marca y actualmente
todavía está en mi habitación
pero la fotografía no se quedó ahí me
dejó pensando actuando y comencé a
escribir acerca de que de la libertad
porque esta foto me recordaba lo que es
la libertad el valor de ser libre esa
frustración que muchas veces tenemos en
la vida diaria y no porque tengamos una
jaula porque a veces nuestro estilo de
vida así es estamos encerrados en
nosotros mismos
entonces vi la fotografía como una
herramienta dije no solamente es andar
allí tomando fotos y capturando momentos
también sirve para crear algo
juan rulfo uno de los escritores
mexicanos más reconocidos también era
fotógrafo
y le debemos a él muchas de las
fotografías de méxico
se le conoce más por su escritura así
pero tiene una faceta de fotógrafo y que
era lo que hacía rulfo tomado imágenes y
creaba historias o viceversa
comencé con inspirarme en rulfo y andaba
por la calle cuando vi a este personaje
inmediatamente me recordó a mi abuelo
materno y dije es mi abuelo materno pero
con una mezcla así como de clint
eastwood no como los ojos así
inmediatamente regresé a la habitación y
dije algo algo tiene que salir de aquí
es como clint eastwood con mi abuelo y
empecé a crear un personaje y no solo
personajes ambientes y este ambiente es
uno de mis favoritos durante mucho
tiempo y durante muchas pesadillas este
fue el escenario cuando era chico extra
mi pesadilla era el cuarto de la casa de
mis abuelos un lugar al que no quería ir
ya entrados los veintitantos me animé y
fui con la cámara y le tomé la foto y me
salí rapidísimo
la fotografía no solamente es la imagen
también sirve para crear otras cosas
como el caso de la pintura hiperrealista
eso que ven ahí es una pintura no es una
foto pero el nivel de detalle es tanto
que se llega a plasmar hasta el vello
facial es algo increíble apoyado
obviamente en la técnica fotográfica o
que me pueden decir de la arquitectura
analizamos los espacios arquitectónicos
por fotos le sirve a los arquitectos
para el estudio de espacios para la
danza el teatro y todas las artes
escénicas
quiero invitarlos entonces a tres cosas
primero volver a los inicios todos
aquellos que tenemos una cámara por lo
menos análoga saquen la muestra en la a
sus hijos a sus familiares a sus amigos
enseñarles cómo se maneja esto
enseñarles lo valioso que es tomar una
imagen y todo lo que requiere tomarla
también
les pido que antes de tomar una
fotografía piensen pero más que pensar
sientan sientan que es lo que estamos
fotografiando
porque comida y todo eso pues sí está
bien pero pero hay algo más tenemos que
escarbar le y decir qué es lo que
realmente quiero plasmar imprimirlo
recordarlo mostrarlo platicar lo a
nuestros amigos y por último que la
fotografía lo utilizan en sus diferentes
profesiones en su vida diaria en sus
hobbies y que lo utilicen como
complemento no lo vean como este cliché
que tenemos de que a la foto pues sí y
modelaje y puros puras el fish y por los
retratos no hay algo más allá es una
herramienta de creación y es una muy
poderosa
los invito entonces a crear esa
conciencia sobre la foto porque las
imágenes que estamos tomando ahorita van
a hablar de nosotros en un futuro
piensen realmente como queremos ser
recordados muchas gracias
[Aplausos]